welcome everybody to the h3 beyond the
experience podcast thank you to Dollar
Shave Club Mint mobile and expressvpn
today for sponsoring us the guests of
course the great bill burr here today
are about great give me someone greatest
guys sitting across from you right now I
know pretty much can close the show I
think thank you thanks guys and that'll
be all first of all very excited for you
playing Madison Square Garden November
7th yes sir
you guys can go get tickets now
billboard.com slash events yeah bu are
are yeah fee you are I also want to give
you credit for i mean f is for family
mm-hmm oh yeah we just wrapped I guess
productions recall on season three so
that should be out on Netflix later on
this year they haven't given me a date
yet but uh they have some sort of
probably in November cuz everything you
have a lot going on in November you got
your new movie coming out the
front-runner I got Thanksgiving you got
Thanksgiving up you got rivalry weekend
the NCAA
there's a lot going on for the great
bill burr but Madison Square Garden
that's crazy is that your have you
played that venue before yeah one other
time okay I forget one 2015 I played it
so now back and hopefully just as good
if not better than the last time how
does it feel cuz that there's like
almost 21,000 seats No how does it feel
playing to that many people verse like
200 people don't call me well it depends
on how you see it like so when I did it
I had the stage onto one side but now
this time I'm doing it in the round so
it's more seats I don't know how I don't
know how many it is but it's you know
what I did the first time was I ended up
you know cuz I'm a big zipline fan and
song remains the same you know that
concert film was shot there so I played
drums so me and the guys from the
goddamn Comedy Jam mhm
Josh Adam ours and all those guys Ben
Bailey came down my publicist played
drums we all just
and healthy arena just attempt on all
these that's Guns N'Roses and rock songs
that we grew up with and it was fun it
turned it into like sort of like it felt
like a more like a like a you know our
Clubhouse for the day
right and yeah you went in you made a
lot of noise and then it didn't just it
didn't seem as crazy
mm-hmm so I went out there and Paul
virzi opened and then Joe DeRosa was on
and Joe had this old sort of what I was
calling a Golden Girls sweater on so I
just made fun of that you know keep
going you know for Paul Rosie and Joe
DeRosa with his [ __ ] Golden Girls
sweater just made me feel like I was at
a comedy club you know and nervous first
shows like that still you know like I
get more like I want people to feel like
they got their money's worth like I want
people to leave like you feel like like
nervous this and all that is is on the
way up and then once you get to a
certain level then it becomes like
responsibility like you spent their
hard-earned money they're coming out
they had to get a sitter it's not like
they just went to a comedy club a let's
watch 10 comics and maybe a couple
drinks yeah I have a couple of yeah this
is like this is an event
so know how to pressure and that uh no I
mean I mean it's it would be a lot of
pressure if I had to do like math like
something I wasn't good at but it's like
this is what I do they're coming to see
me I mean you could do a podcast there
Nana you before well I guess you're not
in front of a crowd but whatever you
know what I mean if you went to whatever
comic-con the broadcasting would you be
nervous yes I'm so neurotic I am nervous
I'm nervous right now okay no trust me
I'm well I'm on edge was there a point
relax thank you
was there a point when you can't kind of
because certainly you felt nervousness
sometime oh no yeah the first years in
my career I mean I would be like I do a
10-minute spot and then on nights where
was a difficult crowd in New York I
would be out of breath and sweating
really
twelve minutes I was telling jokes I
would be sweaty so yeah no no no no I
had all these rituals I had this rule
for years where before I went on stage I
would untie and then retie my shoes cuz
I always worried what if they came
untied and I did a faceplant oh I have I
have that kind of CD [ __ ] drives me
crazy I don't know if that's OCD but
well I depends on what your childhood
was I mean if you had a childhood and
you weren't bullied at all and you still
think like that I would think it was
some sort of OCD but you know you got
kicked out of yourself for a while so
it's LCD you kind of look in this Oh
your Z I don't I'm not gonna diagnose
you I have no idea yeah
so in my case it was probably just you
know my childhood or whatever it's just
like oh you got bullied as a kid yeah oh
boy I did bully I you know it was a get
it off of me and I'd pick on somebody
weaker than me you know I was the Lord
of the Flies course back then so it
wasn't the way it is now where you know
you can go on YouTube and the next thing
you know the bullies crying for some
reason like do you think I feel like
bullies almost important in a way isn't
it like you gotta allow kids to give
each other [ __ ] in a sense I mean you
can't call it gets too much I don't
think it's a parent you ever allow it
sure you know it's it's something no but
I mean I know that there's like like I
have a daughter and I want her to take
some MMA and I just think all women
should know that because I feel like
rapists you know depending on how well
they're endowed at some point they're
gonna have to get in close and I feel
like no like one killer yeah I mean yeah
it's like I would think like when you
watch those women fight in the UFC it's
just like there's I mean there's
probably I mean I would do what I don't
what percentage of the population of
just guys that even know how to fight
fair could beat them and like I don't
think they could because and the second
you get close to these are the
professional level fighters so if the
average woman would learn that I mean
you could get them in a triangle yeah I
said the arm guard I'm trying to member
all the stuff Rogan says like I don't
matter I don't not educated in it but I
just know looking at it that you just
like learn a little self-defense
just some yeah well the fact that you
can be on your back and be in a powerful
position and I just figured like a guy's
gonna try to gorillas way in and try to
hold you down or whatever and then all
of a sudden he's you know he's tapping
out you blow out his elbow and that's an
erection killer right there you blow out
the elbow
I think that's slang for the armbar
although I do see yeah that's part of I
feel like that's a new thing you're
already worried about your daughter
being sexually assaulted you know how
old your dog I don't think that is I
think that's you you projecting your OCD
on me mm-hmm it's all weird you're
talking about you know you want your
your two-year-old daughter to get krav
maga so she could knife a do his neck
yeah but I mean that's like it's not
like you know that didn't accept our
didn't 2014 I mean like stuff like that
is about what it always happened and and
then also you know gives you like
confidence and it really is all you got
to do you know there was elementary
middle and then high school and you know
I feel like somewhere in junior high you
just had to have one fight and fight
back and then it was like prison and
everything I don't you know he's gonna
be a problem and then they would just
move on and the kids who never fought
back its they just have these horrible
experiences so I don't know I just you
know it's just one of those things you
know as a parent I guess what I meant is
like now that you're a parent you're
thinking about things differently
possibly with kids and with your
daughter I mean how is that changed I
would say I'm applying the things I
always thought about because for all
these years of not being a parent I
would watch parents you know dressing
their kids in certain ways and I would
just be like how do you not see that
that is that the [ __ ] that that kid's
gonna get it all right you know what I
mean and it's just like for the love of
God can you give them a fight or son of
a [ __ ] yeah so like yeah I I think you
when you grow up you become one you
either completely forget your childhood
or you have a pretty vivid memory of it
and I you know it's most most of my
channel is positive that's interesting
observation yeah I feel like I forgot
most of it that means it probably had a
decent one right are the good
forget no because I I had I had a
no-good in a but I don't know I don't I
don't know what the amount of
psychologist but I just think like the
people I talked to they either like
remember everything right or it's just
like dude that was a long time ago man
so I think if you don't remember and
then you have a kid you know I wouldn't
want I would rather be the kid of the
parent that remembers right so it's a
yeah how do you forget my mother said
the funniest actually was kind of
heartbreaking
she you know my daughter's only a year
and a half and she was going I just
really enjoy these first three four
years yeah she was really enjoying
before they go to school the other kids
ruin him saddest things you ever said
button and then I was thinking like why
did she think I was ruined and I
probably was on some level that's
interesting that she remembered that
after all these years well because I'm
home from school
yeah but she's gonna send your kids to
school with with people who have kids
that they're not actively involved in
their life
yeah and so then the kids acting out
there the kids on his way to becoming a
problem and then your kid sees that
behavior starts to mimic it like I you
know a lot of my friends obviously have
kids that are older and they just oh
yeah oh yeah like it's just kids that
are just you know the key is not to get
mad at the kid you got to get mad at the
parents if you ever want to punch the
kid you don't do that right don't pop
you can punch the parent punch the dog
I'll give you a t-shirt I just but yeah
I mean I say with dogs now because we
have a dog and we go to the dog park a
lot and things like that and like it's
always don't it's all about not always
but sometimes yeah sometimes I mean I
don't know because dogs I feel like
there's just pure sweet Souls for the
most part and they have to be [ __ ] up
kind of by the owner to be really
dangerous animal there's the dogs that
nature says no to but people say yes to
adorable and then you like the mother
just that this inherently knows that
there's something [ __ ] up with the dog
kicks it away and the things gonna
starve to death and that's too
heartbreaking as a human being in a dog
lover to watch so you give it the bottle
and like you know then one day you see
it's got one red eye
you got the Terminator are you talking
about like an adopted dog or like a
getting a puppy
cuz I feel like when you adopt a dog you
definitely throw the dice a little bit
you know I had a rescue dog
so that was yet a pitbull right that was
my experience yeah and we ended up
having to find her a new home and
fortunately it worked out but she was
human aggressive as they say I spent
thousands of dollars trainers and all
this type of thing I'm like my trainer
and it ended up taking her and it really
it has been like the challenge I think
of his dog wanna be the trainer adopted
the dog yeah took incredible yeah yeah
as he Tad's he managed to tame the
animal now he's been working with her
for two years and she's over the first
time in her life has another dog friend
ah but he was the one who said you know
this is one of these dogs nature's said
no to but people say yes he goes I'm
thinking that that's what it is but
she's an absolute she's one of those
people like if she was just abandoned
again and then came in here and then met
the three of us once she'd be all timid
and when she saw that we were cool and
we're gonna once you fed her and
protecting her
she loved you is she almost love too
hard right right so then and then she be
treating everybody else who came to me
yeah like they were an axe murderer and
we would just never I mean so I had all
these things I used to one of my buddies
uh
Forest we used to just go on hikes and
and it took forever and ever never never
never but he was really good with
animals and she ended up accepting him
and it was the longest you know and I
had to do all like come back to the
house and just just have him you know
stop at the gate and then it was a
little bit behind the gate and then up
to the front door and then and then
those all the him walking in first and
just any little thing could cause like a
setback and it was it was you know it
was emotionally draining yeah yeah so I
mean and she yeah she ended up biting
one of my friends I always keep thinking
that mom when she raced at him there was
a party I should have kicked it because
who said she was on like a hardwood
floor I want to knocked her down you
know wasn't hurt
no she barely because she hadn't done
that before so she did but but how it
works is at first they go to the feet
then they go higher in each time is they
build up and then it's fight and then
grab and and it just you know it's sort
of like an escalating like alcoholic I
mean I'm talking kind of you know I
don't really know a lot of this stuff
and there's be a bunch of people right
now saying okay I just talked about what
my experience that's saying I know
everything about dogs so but that's
that's kind of I was afraid to adopt
because you just never know what you're
gonna get and I people give a [ __ ]
because we bought we bought a dog we
wanted we wanted a purebred puppy or not
a pure bet but we really like the
Maltese in the your keys we just we have
a friend who had to multi so and we
really like them so we're like so wrong
to get a Falcon got a Falcon let's go
any Maltese I know there's no Maltese
just a little fluffy white dog oh it's a
little toy dog New York you watch yeah
that you can pet but we get so much [ __ ]
for having bought a dog but it's like
you know you throw the dice when you you
don't know what these dogs at the pound
have been through you know it's like I
mean we're supposed to do just puppy
mill ones these dogs need to be bought
somebody's got to take care of these
dogs I mean do you need to know what
you're doing when you can get a rescue
to train them right yeah for me for me
it's my first dog so I don't want to
gamble too much and but it's it's crazy
it feels like you like when you're
walking down the street with him before
back Oh why'd you get them and they like
that you didn't buy that dog you it's
like if you care that much sorry this is
something that bothers me if you care
that much about adopting dogs how can
you have a kid you got to adopt kid
right there's kids out there that need a
home how dare you have a kid yeah of
your own if you're not gonna adopt first
heard say margin is basically a puppy
mill yeah I'd agree with that thanks I
got I got this man my theory has been
that if I if I was in your situation I
would just annoy the [ __ ] out of people
I wouldn't have volunteer it I got it at
all yeah yeah purebred I mean yeah it
was like the least sickly looking one
yeah I figured I'd get that one yeah I
love it yeah you just steer into it
I love that honey that's why I was a
yeah I was over in France and like I'm
trying to learn how to speak French I
haven't yeah been bad with it but like
when I go over there you know if you
stink they just start speaking English
and I was just like well if I gotta
listen the English you listening to my
French right and I would just torture
them with it and I would not switch over
and I'd be like I speak English and it's
like I speak French okay this is the
situation way to do yeah well so am I
gonna because you know I lived in Israel
with ela for five years and I succumbed
because every time you know they're like
oh this idiot American I'm gonna speak
English to him and I succumbed
I didn't steer in I wish I steered it
you got it you got to get into the
comedy of it just yet what you remember
their own language it's really funny it
made me look at immigrants differently
like but I guess that immigrants it's
worse because they're actually staying
you know what I mean right I would be
like I would be like back then I'm gonna
be there for ten days I'm not trying to
get employed [ __ ] and I just have a good
time I know I had a great time a great
time doing that I need to get a shirt
that says I bought this dog yeah so you
probably never spent much time at a dog
park because there's a whole thing there
and but it sounds like your dog would
have just gone on a rampage there
probably she was alright initially but
then once she sort of bonded with us
then it became a problem so no we stayed
away from there and then then everybody
else who watches like the dog whisperer
in that and then they tried to be the
guy he's right mr. atlas up yeah
everybody know where so many see if you
would have stated that I did that for a
while like the magic was making that
noise and it's just like now this guy's
been does he even know anything I also
wonder does he just pretend like he
knows and then we believe him you know
what I mean I don't know I mean you
right you really you're people I mean
he's doing this I mean how much what
does that do well I I think the guy
knows what he's doing okay I mean he got
a TV show there's people he did buddy he
worked with a lot of famous people's
dogs know famous people got eaten by
dogs so I would say you know some level
I think that's yeah you're really
cynical guy man that is a lot for me to
say that
yeah but you're not you know what you're
not as gonna close people think I listen
your podcast a lot and you are you're a
very optimistic fair guy there's like a
real fairness behind everything you say
I am it's nice to be listened to
everyone I mean serious you know he's
the king a rage common no I think that's
because you know I used to be a redhead
you know before it left me but I still
have the red beard there's just
something about like you can sort of
openly say that redheads are the
children of Satan and that's that's
totally all good it's all good kick a
ginger day all that [ __ ] does that
bother you though like for real all the
day no it doesn't it just it's it's
freeing because then I don't have to
care about whatever you're crying about
particularly white women complaining
about how difficult it is to live in the
United States of America this is
hilarious right you know I mean I mean
look if you some hillbilly living in a
dirt trail then yeah okay hmm I would
feel bad for you but like other than
that you have a you have you know pretty
wry having red hair no no it's just more
like
no that red hair thing is it's a myth
dude I did great dude when I was single
I did great
yes well I know it was definite I know I
was funny girls I did fine but the
[ __ ] thing that I was like over over
the corner I mean it sucked when I was
growing up yeah definitely because it's
like you got a bull's-eye on top of your
head so but I feel like you know I
always choking people if I had like
brown hair I wouldn't even be in this
[ __ ] business that's great hmm I
don't think money yeah I think I would
be it might be you know just doing some
be a cog in a wheel somewhere yeah then
a dental a dentist possibly as your
mother before you right you were a
dental assistant yes that's interesting
well I mean it's not that interesting
it's interesting if my dad wasn't a
dentist right well did you have ever
plans like before you got into comedy
what point did you decide you wanted to
get a comedy when you were doing like
Dental Assisting or was that just kind
of you always knew you wanted a job I
needed a job and I gotten fired from
this warehouse because there was this
this fat guy it was running she was from
the carpeted area right here used to
come out
you know like the typical douche who
like just gets a little bit of power and
it just I don't know what it and then
they just go pure evil I don't know what
no you didn't go pure evil but he just
he just walked out there like he had
accomplished something like I don't know
what like here like an astronaut sort of
gate the way he was walking so he used
to come out there and everybody would
seem coming and then try to like work oh
look at me cutting up the box and look
at me you know doing this [ __ ] and I
just I was like [ __ ] this guy so I
wouldn't do that if anything I would I
would step off the gas a little bit of
it hey what's up man damn I didn't do
that where do you get the would you I
like it was sabotage feel like I have I
feel like everyone wishes they had that
right there where you're like you know
what [ __ ] this guy I'm gonna work less I
don't have that in me that had I loved
that but that has to be applied
correctly right point you need to work
as a team plane crash maybe should go
this way lead me out of the woods but
like not [ __ ] everyone it's [ __ ] these
guys that don't deserve my respect well
yeah so I didn't work as hard and then I
and I was due for a raise and then I
asked for a raise and magically I got
laid off yeah the economy was bad and I
couldn't get a job and I needed one of
my dad was like well won't you come work
with me for a little bit and I did and
it was it was great because I got I got
I worked with him for five years and oh
wow
and I got to sort of you know by not
seeing with Dad just seeing him as a
dentist like I kind of got to figure him
out and understand him more so it was a
great thing and then also I learned so
much about you know teeth and all the
headaches that it can cause right ya
know like I don't think I'd still take
x-rays cuz they switched up the
machinery so long ago since when I did
it but I could still take impressions
poor him up I still not the old school
where we tap on that vibrating thing to
get all the rifles out of there's
nothing worse then if there was a bomb
because the bubble would always seem to
go down to the bottom so did another one
would always be right where the tooth
was and then like the bubble wouldn't
take the employed kill that impression
that that part of it you talk about when
you put like
clay in someone's mouth yeah and then
Adam can't just repour it because the
the dunk shrinks and then you have to
redo it and if you had a gag er and you
had to read it I was a [ __ ] guy I
puked at the dentist when they took
really well yeah I was a gag er man
broke my heart one of those bubbles
popped in my mold ya know there was just
like I used to just what other kind of
crazy [ __ ] you do is it you ever get in
people's mouths or were you just on stam
yeah it took out stitches and I was
certified to take x-rays and yeah I was
about the extent of it so when did that
end and did it end when you started
doing comedy no I was doing I was doing
okay dates and I was and it was
hilarious my dad you know back then he
worked from 7:00 to 7:00 I never saw
anybody he was a 7 a.m. patient he used
to work on like like prisoners people in
the correctional thing cops he would
work out yeah he like he was like a
force of nature hmm like he did the work
of three dentists so I wanted to work
with the other dentists because it was
just like I could actually get a lunch
we stand we stand um people up I'd be
numbing people up and then race out
while they were getting numb and just
wolf down slice of pizza
oh you'd be on your feet the whole day
is just like no I got my work ethic both
my parents work extremely hard and their
whole lives I mean they're older now so
they're retired and stuff but like but
just watching how hard they worked and I
think that that is one of the main
reasons why I got this gig coming up in
New York mm-hmm was you know it was a
combination of learning that's what
working is and then coming up in the
Boston comedy scene were like what was
considered killing there you know what
was considered just getting the job done
was killing in some of these other
cities that I went to but like there so
it was just laying grounds ya know they
murdered it was a guy Kevin Knox rest
his soul he used to host the show and
Patrice rest his soul he used to say
Kevin doesn't host the show as much as
he just like takes breaks from killing
so he would like murder and then you
would get it we used to compare it's
like a giant wave you get up there
just try to ride it and and he really
took it personally if you bombed on his
show because he felt like the crowd
looked at him like keV you [ __ ] us
like who was that like he took it
personally responsible like he was the
GM putting together a championship team
so and we used to tell horror stories
about having to follow what you have to
follow his Star Trek bid or his drunk
driving bid they were just all they all
murdered and so I yeah it was probably
you know that whole thing so I have a
very low level of patience for people
that dog it at their jobs and I don't
give a [ __ ] if you hate your job just
going in there and just not doing a good
job it's just like it's just like then
quit yeah but like don't make everybody
else around you suffer like it's it's
kind of like it's [ __ ] like you
signed up to do this job do the [ __ ]
job and and I really don't have any
sympathy for people who don't work hard
and you know and they're not getting
where they want to be in life if you're
making an effort and you're still
getting [ __ ] and that's like somebody
I'll try to help out but like if you
just like not putting in every minute
yeah you're [ __ ] over the person
you're currently working for and then
ask him like where your brass ring is
it's like well I mean it's not how the
world works what is this you've probably
heard this a lot that people say that
dentists are like high rate of suicide
what is it is there something to that
have you heard that I I think everybody
heard that growing up but I never knew
what not true I've never known one that
killed himself so yeah did you [ __ ] well
it sounds like it was stressful but not
suicidal yeah obviously
yeah he never killed me yeah you see if
that's what you're a yeah is this the
Oprah part were you gonna try to get me
to cry yeah well I got enough he taught
about it one night
yeah I just thought that was interesting
thing it's just one of those things you
hear and you're just like accept it on
face value like oh yeah dentists just
salt they're all killing themselves yeah
there was all of those things and there
was to think guy who put the pack of
firecrackers and the kids back pocket
and lit it and blew half his ass off and
he never heard that one these might be
older ones before your guys time but
there was a there was he's think candies
called pop rocks oh yeah I know the pop
so the thing was somebody swallowed a
whole
bag and his stomach exploded and he died
yeah like all of those type writings
existed so I don't know what the new
ones are all right he was on his iPad
and he fell asleep yeah and he burned
his face I'm sure trying to update the
technology that's a good one I think
that's true actually I heard that so
let's take a quick break we're gonna go
to a quick commercial break we got a lot
to get to am i coming back after the
blow me back guys are you coming back
after the break
I certainly hope so as well stay tuned
thank you to Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this episode now have you
guys seen pulp fiction you know the
scene at the end of that movie where he
opens the briefcase and it's glowing
gold and you don't know what's in it
well I finally do know what's in it
because Dollar Shave Club look at this
you see the or look at these packs of
one wipe Charlies oh my god first of all
this has nothing to it the copy read I
just wanted to give my shout out
oh man I can't wait for that smell to be
replaced with the putrid scent my
rotting [ __ ] got enough about that
let's get thank you to Dollar Shave Club
because you guys already know what's up
you got a look and feel and smell and
have your [ __ ] smelling the very best
they got it all boys they got
toothbrushes toothpaste and of course
razors and shaving butter that's how I
get ready you've got to get ready with
Dollar Shave Club because they've got
the best products you don't have to go
to the freakin store it's the most
affordable guys I don't know what we're
missing we're all guys right no oh oh
there's girls - guess what they also
need to shave yeah and brush their teeth
yeah so what are we all doing they've
got the answers right here Dollar Shave
Club okay and right now you can get
ready with an amazing deal on any one of
their starter sets I recommend the daily
essential starter set because I love the
amber lavender body cleanser why do they
make me say that like I love all their
pod you don't why are you specifically
are they well anyway that one is amazing
their marketing team I just find it
let's call it something specific yeah
the lavender come on guys I just thought
this is the one it's the one wife
Charlie all right
but you can't go wrong with any of them
and that I do agree with head on over to
dollarshaveclub.com / h3 to pick up your
own Dollar Shave Club starter set for
just how much five frickin dollars on
the table okay give me a break after
your starter set product ship at regular
price and make sure you check out their
new video - that's a dollar shave I
don't know what that video is mm-hmm it
could be something really obscene oh no
I'm probably not
that's dollarshaveclub.com /h 3 dollars
shave club comm /h 3 guys they got the
best razors they got the best [ __ ] they
got everything you freaking need five
dollars on the table tried Dollar Shave
Club thank you to Mint
Mobil for sponsoring us I love this
product because phone lines are so
effing expensive it's ridiculous I
remember when we lived in Israel and
when we were dead broke there was foam
companies that were selling their
product for like $10 a month and it
saved our lot like it's actually saved
our life we were so broke and here if
you want to get a plan it's like a
hundred freaking dollars
it's insane so that's what I'm so happy
to see mint mobile because they are that
disrupter that's given a good service at
a fair price okay now I want to read
this coffee they've got because it's
hilarious they're sending shots out to
the world the big and big wireless
stands for a lot of things big contracts
big bills and big fees what's up now
shots fired like AT&T s new 800 million
dollar administrative fee increase MIT
mobile doesnt f around any of that [ __ ]
cuz guess what they cost just fifteen
dollars a month
Wow that's a game-changer dude they make
it so easy to cut your wireless bill
down all they do is send you this card
in the mail and guess what you know what
that is it's SIM card you plug it in
your phone Bob's your uncle $15 a month
I'm telling you it changed my life when
I had this opportunity in Israel choose
between two five 10 gigabyte 4G LTE
plans no more paying for unlimited data
that you don't even need every plan
comes with unlimited talk and text and
if you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their 7-day
back gear and teeth did you ditch your
old wireless bill and start saving with
mint mobile yet it's about time guys go
right now set up your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month plus free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card go
to mint mobile.com / h3 that is mint
mobile cobs / h3 cut your wireless bill
to $15 a month and get free shipping on
your SIM card guys mint mobile.com / h3
guys they are listening and they are
watching and this is not me being
paranoid they're out there lurking ready
to steal your data right BAE who is they
if you need to know who's they they are
already ahead of you they the government
the ISP the people sitting at the
airport being like oh free airport
internet cool time to steal your
passport your credit card they ela are
all out there and they're preying on the
weak Lambs of the world that's why you
need to get expressvpn you're making
online purchases or accessing your email
and an unsecured network or even from
home because the highest P's can see
everything you're making a big mistake
ok
you were being tracked expressvpn has
easy-to-use app that runs seamlessly in
the background of any computer phone or
tablet you turn on expressvpn protection
it takes one click boom protected
see you later haters I was going to flip
off the camera but I thought maybe
that's too obscene expressvpn secures
and anonymizes your internet browsing
history everything that's going on
encrypts your data hide your public IP
address you are set to go
ok forget about hentai ok we can live
with hentai the government doesn't care
if you're watching head or whatever is
even weirder than that what I do care is
that people don't get my credit card
information don't get my passport ok
this is the kind of things that are
important to keep secure I don't want to
be another stat and Facebook's
advertising gambit
or Russian propaganda machine ok protect
your online activity today and find out
how you can get three months free at
expressvpn calm
/ a tree that's expr ESS VPN exp ress
VPN comm / h 3 / 3 months free with a 1
year package visit expressvpn dot-com /
h3 to learn more thank you we are back
with the great great greatest Bilborough
I do mean that I know it makes you
uncomfortable it does one great was bad
enough but you know that I like being
appreciated yeah okay just say Tony back
with the person I appreciate
oh really yes back with he worth the
money okay definitely worth the money
guys Madison Square Garden
yes what was that November 7th in New
York City head on over to bill bird comm
/ events and I do want to say guys you
all have Netflix
everyone has Netflix statistically half
of Americans maybe even more have
Netflix that's incredible right that
means that everybody should be watching
f is for faith is for family I say even
more people have it considering how easy
it is to steal somebody's right so I
don't care about that that blows my mind
I mean I think that's like this this
gene my level leave loss like it's yeah
but then we'll get them addicted to it
someday that relationships going to fail
and they're only gonna be halfway
through narcos and they have to see the
ending and that's we're gonna get there
but that but like they were so ahead of
the game because all these companies
with passwords with access they're so
tight asked about it do be like oh you
can only log in to computers that wants
Netflix going back a decade said no
everyone on the block everybody you know
can use your account and look at him now
who's [ __ ] laughing no I guess they
are f is for family guys check it out
and laughing now yeah I want to show you
some videos ok I thought I would lighten
I don't know if you're gonna like this
one this one I don't know say it was
risky but risky I don't know we'll see
what you think this is an old classic
you may have seen it you don't have to
say anything I just want you to enjoy it
is that a move you know this is us check
us out that was incredible
you want to do that again that was like
breakdancing right there no that's a
move absolutely I think his face got
kind of probably kind of roughed up I
think that's absolutely a move the face
grind watch him watch how control-d is
the second you sliding on your face you
don't want to be your arms are gonna fly
out right he was just like well they
have a different center about nice like
Hawkins not like Shh if it's a move then
that's all let's just watch his arms
watch his arms he was pushing to to try
to get another mean there extra foot
that they're ahead of the game guys I
want to see more of those well I've
never thought about it as it being a
movie yeah once again the great mind
that's appreciate so here I want to ask
how nuts did the crowd go when he did
that I mean it's something I got the gig
what are you gonna do alright I got
plenty of little people all right we're
gonna do it in duck all right I got what
you finishing back the face slide yeah
the face Christ whatever you want to
call it on the deli face exactly so I
want to ask you about one of the great
moments and you're one of my favorite
moments in your career that I've always
appreciated
I don't even pop this up for reference
for us the audience I want to ask you
about sherry berries make section so you
had I'm just gonna catch him up you had
a advertiser called Sherry's berries and
while you were reading the coffee you
just you couldn't hold it together
because my first time reading the copy
yeah it was just so homophobic and
homoerotic at the same time that I just
it was it was so silly I couldn't we was
actual cops and it's just so ridiculous
the premise like I've never heard
anything like that being advertised
evidently they're delicious
still still make covered yeah and they
dropped me after a while no what
happened was I had Harris Stanton was on
and they was like we have strawberries
you know drip you know a dunked in white
we have you know in dark chocolates I go
and I've just jokingly said to him he's
black I said how come the white
chocolate comes before this it was not
riffing on the Klan or something and
then I don't know how I don't know
people who think there are strawberries
are made by the Klan I don't know what
they was saying right
yeah I'm still sad they left I loved
don't share yeah I mean dude how many
ads go viral I've been thinking about
I've never bought Sheree's bear well
they told me to take this down really
and then on it cuz on the end I said you
guys better buy this [ __ ] cuz I'm in
trouble and then people bought it and
then they quickly were smart enough to
be like okay leave it up leave it up
then we had this really cool thing where
I felt like cherries bear they get me
it's we we now know what happened
somebody new came in or maybe somebody
saw a black Klansmen the original cut of
it right you know before it came out now
what do you look or maybe I was gonna
say we listened to it so many times it's
like one of our well so let me let me
update the the audience here with a
little sherry Aries also have delicious
products such as Christmas cake pops
cheesecakes and dipped pretzels here's
the only way to get this special 1999
Sherry's berries offer yeah that's so
much so did they I really just wanted to
know how did they react to that but it
sounds like at first they they reacted
like you Holly well I have this thing on
my pot I never talked to the advertisers
I'm never available and if like yeah
either get what I do or you don't and I
understand I understand if you don't to
be associated with her my stupidity
but if you do I think I can help you
sell some stuff like the baby well the
thing is is people can fast forward
through the ads so the show can't stop
oh you got it you got to do something
right yes make it one yeah I like on
Howard Stern I love when he burps during
the wreath it just it always makes me
laugh and it always sounds like the same
one like her it's doing it but like I it
always makes me laugh whatever you
it's just something hilarious about
somebody burping while reading
advertising so I actually look forward
look forward to his reads I look forward
to Yuri's I love listening to your reads
because well let me ask you this do do
you get in trouble a lot when you do
reads because a lot of your reads are
like I was listening to your one of your
recent podcasts you're talking about
sports betting you're like I don't like
I don't [ __ ] sport because they make
you say like words in your mouth yeah
maybe like you bet you win them like
yeah all you lose and your wife leaves
you I mean it's this degrees there but
these sponsors get upset no no I think
at this point that gets kind of been
established this is what he does that
it's done yeah so they'll just be like
they like I haven't lost an avatar I
shouldn't say this but I haven't lost
one in about three months four months
yeah so that's been active running
that's good it's a good run my favorite
one I wish I could have the Hall of Fame
of the one and done I'm trying to think
who they were the only one I could ever
remember is naturebox
and I think I know what I thought it was
nature's box-like possessive so I was
like you're going down on mother nature
yeah but as you're laughing I read
another three lines a copy and you're
getting information and they just didn't
see they didn't find the humor in it
naturebox
I think they went under actually yeah
most stupid they just was ringing we
weren't we failed them they're bringing
you a banana and it's just like well I
mean I could [ __ ] can't do this
yourself like what they were offering
was an axe yeah what's next yes the next
snack you taking it wait five seconds
out of your day you can probably do this
yourself you ever get asked for make
goods when you do ads
what do you mean like if I screw they
say they say you got to do another one
for free because you messed up the first
one I don't recall anybody ever talking
to me in that tone
they don't you guys you good ah you got
a big is me free because no one is still
living yeah so let me tell you someone
we get the [ __ ] all the time I don't get
this I don't get that respect you don't
get what I don't get that respect people
ask me for me get again oh I know there
was didn't know this condition that I've
screwed up but I said there's a buffer
between me and them yeah so I love that
so Andrew who runs will be like yeah
listen these guys they were a little
upset about just [ __ ] read it again
so I got a cold reading so I it but I
don't get the whole whatever sit down
mafia sit down that you get so you did
get him read it again I don't know you
don't even know his bus yeah ignorant no
I am ignorant but you don't I'm but I'm
smart enough to know that you don't talk
to you after it's like I didn't get in a
podcast thing to do of a [ __ ] a
conference call with you [ __ ] guys
talking about this shirt you're trying
to sell it well I get it it's a shirt no
you wrote what you're gonna say just
like I don't want to listen you guys
like you're just trying to fill up your
day so many people in those [ __ ]
corporations they're just trying to
justify their desk yeah then reach the
hole I hate when the conference call
ends and then you hear this voice that
you haven't heard hole call and it's
like you were afraid that everyone was
gonna hang up and you didn't say yeah so
now you're in a panic mode so then they
just throw something out there and you
have to address it like it's a
legitimate comment when it isn't it's
just like you know you go through a lot
of those because you went from being
working kind of day jobs to doing comedy
full-time I presume barely do them
anymore but I used to that's what I used
to do when I had conference calls on
scripts or anything what I would do
would I would put the phone on speaker
and I would throw it to the other side
of the bed and then I would listen if
she got video I would literally lay on
the bed like with my arm across my eyes
and I would just wait for people to stop
talking then I just be like
you know it sounds good all right so I
don't know why I can watch so many hours
of sports yet I can't even I can't even
like I can't handle more than if they
drive me insane
well I like texting yeah almost you
don't eat phone calling some on the
phone it's almost like Anna same thing
to do these tech rude it's like tip what
unless you have some sort of intimate
relationship right you know I mean if I
call it you loads it's important what
happened if I call you the if I thought
if I caught you at a chitchat what did
you do
that'd be weird jail if ela called me I
was like hey how you doing I'm like okay
what what is it you know what I mean
like what I feel like since we've we had
the kid my wife finds me calling her
know it's annoying because she either is
in the middle of a [ __ ] storm or she
finally got a break and then Mike dumb
ass is gonna be super market just like I
just I wanted to tell you about this
make good we got and I think I need to
remove myself because it's actually
drove me crazy it was funny though they
said I said when I was doing a copy read
get your free trial for $5 but what was
written was 495 and they said you have
to do it again for free because you said
five dollars instead of 495 you should
have just said well I'm not doing that
we did and they said okay yeah they're
bluffing they're holding nothing yet you
have to do it again for free no I know
but no it is totally a game of being
it's that but it's better because you
went higher so then oh my god I just
saved a nickel I love this body exactly
it's a twist yeah you know if you said
like you know for 50 and then they find
out it's for 95 then they have a 45 so
now it's now we got a problem on hand
okay yeah now you have a conference call
now chime in on that how do you as a fan
of your podcast the Monday morning
podcast everybody who's not listening
the money more podcast please do because
it is my favorite how do you prepare for
that podcast because you sit down you
talk and I
swear to god it's like you're doing
material but yeah I know you're just
talking but like I always wonder how do
you prepare do you prepare it all for
your podcast i Andrew sends me the
advertising yeah I copy the producer yep
I copy and paste it and then he sends me
the questions for the week I copy and
paste that and I stick it under the ads
I never broken down my whole game thing
my game film and then what I do is I'll
just write Pat's game you know topics
big feet blah blah whatever and then I
just start talking and if it's not going
well I go to the list if it goes great I
barely look at the list and all of a
sudden I look down and I've done like a
half hour and haven't even done the read
yet I know that the question is one I'm
gonna take like 20 minutes or so and
yeah that's basically how I do it now
but through when you're going throughout
the week in between podcasts do you take
notes of [ __ ] you want to talk about or
do you sit down you're like oh I
remember that I want to talk about that
no like I decide on topics as I just sit
down and I just thought and I'm just
like [ __ ] what happened to me I know
something happened like you know the
anecdote about like you were making a
sandwich and the lady was she asked for
a special thing and the lady was just
like no oh my god but which was so funny
but I would remember cuz you know what I
hated about the guy was he was he was on
like his tiptoes watching I were at a
bagel and if visualize yeah he wanted
butter on him and you know it's a
[ __ ] Airport yeah and they got like
the little the little you know a little
conveyer belt thing and they sent it
through nice he was just sitting there
like like a meerkat right and and he was
just annoying me cuz I've had that job
it's just like we just met him make the
thing and be done with it and he just
say oh could you could you just put the
butter on it I would just put the butter
and she was just like she was like a
grizzled vet she was like what can you
just I just wanted can you can you put
the butter on it now you know before I
got dredgers she goes the butters over
there he goes no no I was just hoping
can you spread it now so like cuz it's
still warm I want it to be melted can
you do that she just goes now I love
that
like half a cigarette hanging out what
do you want is a ham and cheese but I
guess that that memory was you you have
a good memory I think because I don't
think I would have held on to even even
something that precious but you've
always got I mean you do it twice a week
to if there's a lot of time to fill but
you you somehow capture these memories
and retell it in a way that you know I
got it you italic clip my favorite a
little bit uh on my podcast is because
I'm making my wife laugh which is my
favorite thing is the greatest cutest
and thank you I can be adorable I told
her this story of I first told the story
of watching this old guy wipe out on a
scooter sliding on his face and then it
reminded me of this time I saw this guy
this guy in Griffith Park was in street
clothes and went down the steepest hill
and wiped out and I was telling the
story it was like a Sherry's berry thing
that it started making me laugh and then
my wife started laughing and you know
that story that listening heard her
laugh and that's why we got married that
that whole story about the chemistry and
that whole thing like I listen you know
I listen I go back and I listen to that
like once a year
and now I feel lucky that I know that's
somebody that has like she's as funny as
most comedians I know and she has an
incredible sense of humor and it's kind
of uh it was yeah it was just something
that you know someone like me being a
lunatic I needed someone like that that
could laugh that hard it's somebody
falling off me by the way well she's in
the business she worked on Chappelle's
Show
but she did I was on season two she was
on season actors or no she was what was
she on that I forget what she was on
that one but on tough crowds when I met
her she was a talent coordinator but she
also was an actor he's a better actor
than I am every bit is funny so she's
like one of those people that is so good
at everything it's trying to figure out
you know what which direction to go in
where I am a one-trick pony that's not
true
if you really look at
if you look close yeah if you look at
the credit wow this guy's great give me
a break
yeah I played Frank Murphy who's a loud
screaming jackass I do say Bob screaming
jackass I do my podcast out in the movie
driving over here loud screaming jackass
you're playing yes so why CDC yeah
a CDC say no three courts but seriously
the movie does seem to not to be a
departure from the loud screaming
jackass which movie the one that's going
on frontrunner oh my god yeah I mean you
get a look I saw from the trailers not
that much information but you seem to be
playing a very sincere detective so I
understand that role I'm playing a
reporter
Oh your report okay who works for the
maderas who mysteriously still possesses
my Boston accent cue grant well I think
it's gonna get nominated for an Oscar
like in between takes is speaking like
us he's Australian that's what it talks
like and then and actually there's these
[ __ ] Gary Hart that blows my mind
that amazing I probably shouldn't it's
because as opposed to me who just
memorizes lines and tries to make it
sound believable well I can't wait that
movie looks really good it really when I
saw the trailer it's amazing and I have
to start learning everybody else's name
in it because I was only on it for and
with a limited amount of actors because
everybody just crushes it as punching
you know to me they're kids I'm 50 so
their own in their 20s and 30s and I was
just like you know I could was kind of
watching go like here's the next batch
like these men and women are gonna be be
doing stuff so I'm very happy for all of
those people are you it's hard to tell
from the trailer but is it a major role
in the film or is it more of a like kind
of secondary character more like a
fourteenth okay okay okay all right yeah
do you want to ask them more movies you
seem to enjoy it I love I know I don't
know I really it's it's weird now that I
have a kid but I learned on that one
that the next time I'm just gonna rent
the place and bring my wife and kid
nice it's doing to way that was yeah
that was hot oh my god my kid today was
coolest thing ever like she occasionally
now speaks and we'll do two words you
know she's not shy or anything like that
so she had to get one of her shots today
and she's been over there a bunch of
times so she knows so she got other
doctors and she was like you know
getting all nervous like a dog go to the
vet so you know shoot into a little cute
little thigh and like she's sitting
there and she shot her and you know gave
her this shot and she starts crying and
she goes okay it's over in the sheet
when she said yes she looked at the
nurse she goes oh done five five like
broke my heart and I was proud that she
said three words and she totally
communicated like right yeah oh it seems
like you're in love with your daughter
hearing you talk about her on the
podcast well you're pretty perceptive
listen more than that okay because again
you're this character you gush you gush
over your daughter not everyone gushes
did your dad gush over you I mean I was
too little ya know my dad was my dad
actually at worked it at work that's
when I learned like oh my god yeah he
really likes us when he came home he
wasn't cracking the whip that make
you're doing your studies well why not
you know is that [ __ ] you also had a
zillion kids so I mean yeah really how
many siblings give I don't know dude the
Internet's too [ __ ] weird to give out
all that information oh you don't even
want to say how many because you're
afraid that it was yeah my all be my
you're talking about it is anybody can
have this out I'm honest dude like
there's yeah no yeah this [ __ ]
lunatics out there okay well off the air
off the year geez I love how surprised
he is geez well I mentioned the amazing
people okay know what I gotta do what
you have to do is just consistently lie
and change name I do have friends that
do that I don't think I'm smart enough
to do that but I have friends who are
you to Vern approach that they're
front-facing persona that everyone knows
them by their name and everything is a
complete fabrication yeah and they're
brilliant I wish I thought about that
because that we've had creepy people
coming to our house they probably the
same [ __ ] that created a lot of this
spyware [ __ ] like if you already think
of that or they just said or they are
smart you know but yeah if I could mom I
could never do it all over again because
of what I do I need social media but if
I wasn't you know a performer if I was a
manager or anything like that I would
have a website but I would not be on
social media at all interesting yeah all
right know what on my part tell me about
all things comedy I don't know you say
I'm nervous I'm sweating I'm just gonna
let you sit I know you are you don't you
gotta push through the other side no
touching
if you were a leaver on the other team
I'd come out and check you for Vaseline
or something punched your hair a little
too many times he's doctoring the ball I
regroup mmm you being in that and having
a kid we have been trying to have a kid
and the longer it takes we also kind of
second a question the whole thing like
should we have a kid it's awesome it's
one of the few things that truly lives
up to the hype
all these years are being lied to about
these summertime movies it's awesome and
you know what do I know I'm only a year
and a half in so my year-and-a-half
experience has been incredible and the
only advice I would give you is don't
listen to 90% of other parents because
for some reason they take a joy out of
trying to ruin the experience oh you
wait this is your first one everything's
gonna change no more drinking oh my god
guys leave now it's they just hang you
with all this dread and I always thought
I was just kind of like you sound like a
terrible father like you don't sound
like you're enjoying it well why didn't
you say all that positive stuff you
can't you don't mean like that's just
it's just how people just like to
complain and they like knowing [ __ ] yeah
exactly so
like pass on the knowledge yeah it's
just like but in an annoying way ya know
like uber the optimist I'm telling ya -
you know I I'm I am not what people
think I want to ask you about all things
comet you've got what what is all things
comedy is it a production company is it
a podcasting Network I mean this is a
company that's everything it's ever it's
everything it's first it started off we
you know years ago we were watching the
whole podcast thing exploding and then
watching what always happens like the
artists creative scene mm-hm and then
the business man comes in as I okay
here's the deal
I'm gonna wrangle all this up I'm gonna
own it but you're gonna get all this
info sure you're gonna have to tap dance
for the rest of your night and I'm gonna
have a [ __ ] yacht in five years right
so we're like well why what's stopping
us at this point the technology had come
about where you could actually start
your own thing and there was podcast
networks out there where they were doing
this thing where they owned a percentage
o of it yeah well I owned your podcast
support well and everybody going do
don't you don't have to give that away
but like you see that kind of stuff on
YouTube a lot - right but a lot of
people from my generation you know weird
like a prison kind of thing you were
institutionalized but you just saw I
can't own anything I need you go -
bigger thing it's like no dude you have
your own TV right here your own channel
so we tried to do more of a co-op where
everybody owns the thing owns their
podcast and that yeah so that's
basically and we all hype each other's
projects or Z's one of the guys our
network network from the Diversey effect
podcast when he had his first comedy CD
come out we all tweeted about it at the
same time and he put out a great album
and that came together and he went
number one on iTunes and bough both the
United States and in Canada as an
unknown at that point and now we just
produced a stand-up special for him for
Comedy Central and Comedy Central has
bought three more hours from us so we're
going to produce so now and now we kind
of get to pick people that we like these
these guys men and women that we think
are hilarious so
and so then you know I'm currently
writing a movie and you know we recently
partnered with soap box films and you
know you know I'm writing with somebody
who isn't with all things county but if
he like said we're gonna drive it
through there and just kind of build
this thing up and and the whole thing
was you know to do this trying to do it
the right way was was quite a task but
we just we just don't we wanted to have
comedians to have a frigging rail light
that they could go to where everybody
wasn't just trying you know to [ __ ] you
over like on like on specials and stuff
like this [ __ ] that goes down really
that yeah the stuff that goes down you
mean like slices of the pie going in all
different directions like people having
side deals with networks that suck or
going out of business you know that's
something that we ran into and it's just
like hey every special you bring us to
you you get you get 60 grand so then all
of a sudden this 60 grand is now going
to tell you hey go to this [ __ ]
Network instead of like yeah Netflix or
something where it's going to be seen
yeah and it's just like like yeah that's
only the tip of the iceberg and then
like you know expenses and all this
right all this stuff and like sky-high
expenses with no accountability yes all
of that type well the thing was you know
back in the day it was like you know I
swear to god there were some people that
literally had like inside people like
TMZ has at the airports to say you know
what celebrities are going through like
they would literally have incite people
to network and they would figure out
what your budget was because you get in
business with a production company and
you'd be like what can you shoot this
for it's like well how much money you
guys I'm gonna [ __ ] tell you that and
they would somehow I swear to God like
if you had a million dollars they'd be
like we did the budget is you mean like
999 thousand uh and then if you had like
nine bucks to be like its we $8.99 like
they are they always like vacuumed up
everything but that final [ __ ] eight
percent and then you know that they went
out and they shot the thing for like 70
yeah like not even probably whatever
whatever the number was yeah and they
just skimmed this just took it not skim
and dude they took a giant [ __ ]
shovel out of there all right and you
know that's the one thing that they only
like that the one thing that has been
really
disappointing getting into the business
world because I know it's not just the
business that I am but just the level
you say the business world you mean own
an accordion and oh just because
entertainment business has a bad rap but
it's just straight across the board the
the level of just unabashed stealing
that happens in business and they
justify it
no no they they sleep like babies yeah
it's it's so rampant that I don't even I
don't understand people that like steal
like you like anybody if you're a thief
like you should be working towards
getting on the legal side of stealing
because there's probably more stealing
on the legal side of socially [ __ ] and
now you don't have to hide the car it's
all above board or whatever and she say
you know you see things like Lord of the
Rings it gross like how many billions of
dollars yeah like the director had to
like sue like better Jackson sued that
day you didn't pay him they're right
they were saying they were not in in
profit and it's a routine thing like I'm
letting you know right now move it is it
is a routine experience to be in one
side of what are these big conglomerates
pitching the sequel well while in the
other side of the building in the legal
department you're suing them for nothing
the first that is so fun yeah and just
like I'm auditing and all of it all of
that with what they have this [ __ ] I've
seen I've been through these clauses
we're like you can audit us and if
there's less than a 5% discrepancy you
have to pay for it five is good I
usually get like 12 how do you how do
you [ __ ] up paying me 12% yeah so and
then oh it's accounting its numbers yeah
then you have to pay for the audit you
uh so they kind of gave themselves a
license to steal
exactly exact that's all that means okay
I saw my first constants what we legally
owe you but we're gonna write this in so
we can steal this and then if they're
really greedy they'll actually go like
beyond it no there there are some well
they have nothing to lose cloaking
characters out there yeah the first time
I saw that clause I was like okay so I
have a 5% discrepancy which bit means
you're gonna take five
more than you there and that is
considered being difficult if you say
that my yeah that's the which to me
means what difficult difficult to steal
from yeah all the time cuz yeah in
YouTube in the beginning there was so
much of that going on and we would not
let it slide on us so I remember they
had this thing where if any of your
videos get flagged then you dumb
[ __ ] can take your revenue yeah
you can't what I said you don't get the
advertisements I said oh so you don't
run the ad no we still run it well then
he [ __ ] gets it taking it what it yes
so what is some I would have a whole
team of people at YouTube just flag and
[ __ ] there are that's what they do
confidence like that I'm dealing with
this [ __ ] all the time what happens is
if you're a copyright holder and I
mention you like we have a video just
talking about something and I mention a
clip right maybe I show it for a split
second so they've got people probably
just some interns low-level grunts that
just claim it and they get the money
it's so and they make so much money like
that because they just mass and do it
you know my thing is when they're in the
meeting and they present doing that they
presented like they're on a good mission
like you guys aren't there and they're
basically presented a how they're going
you're on a crusade to protect their
copyright yeah that's what they yeah we
have to protect our copyright because
there's all these pirates online
stealing content and we're standing up
for ourselves no but I'm saying like if
they feel like what you said was
offensive to somebody they would flag it
like and [ __ ] oh yeah then I [ __ ] it's
just like that's gonna be every clip
yeah it's frustrating but yeah it's it
can be really frustrating especially
when you spend like a whole week working
on a video because that's a lot of
youtubers will post like one video a
week right and then all of a sudden some
[ __ ] is just like mine that's my
money now how like because they quite
they'll claim it may be you showed some
of their work and there's a fair use
which means that you're allowed by us
copper on talking about ripping people
off I'm just talking about you put up
your own original content yeah I'm
talking about you no no it's it's
original content but you if we talk
about something like like in a news way
or react
or talking or criticizing you know sue
you can do yeah but you up but then you
have to get that rep out there that you
do that if this is the bullying thing
again like I know don't [ __ ] with the h3
podcast man these guys know suey it's
not worth the headache we've been for
you pretty big on you one
yeah that's great when's the movie
coming out man wasn't feel good at the
time but it was uh you know I don't give
a [ __ ] if they were recovering from that
but I'm sure this is what goes on in
show biz is is well I don't know what
goes IQ straight across all business
yeah almost war there's no way down to
the business of a stand-up special
that's like the people that are always
you know with the shovel not skimming
shoveling money out there's such [ __ ]
rich just so rich all the time too and
it's like they just cannot be fair I
don't know yeah that's the thing like I
I just wish I could talk to him and just
like ask them well I mean I'm you know
I'm not a perfect person I mean that's
just you know where I [ __ ] up in other
areas of my life maybe this is just
their thing but I I just you know
[ __ ] some you know college kid out of
the money on his on his page I don't
know or some new comic on a special and
so anyways that so this basically that's
why we started you know all things
comedy and now it's just grown into this
thing we you know we're gonna produce
some TV shows we're starting to sign
some deals and that's awesome yeah and
it's those are like a management uh know
you represent them no no we're the
conglomerate yeah we like a production
you can also like you know whatever you
would want to do the soap box films they
they literally and it's a it's a union
yeah they edited like the Muppet movies
and all of them these guys can handle
any [ __ ] idea that I ever have in
there so while all the comics are I love
I mean you got you have so much talent
there and your YouTube channels amazing
a love actually we're doing something's
burnin burnin
oh yeah blinks burking yeah Bert Bert
Bert crushes why I'm here he told me he
goes yeah be less Bert such a sweetheart
do you watch youtube videos at all yeah
I love you too really um I like lions
killing hyenas it always annoys me that
they [ __ ] come over and they take
this [ __ ] you know and then the Lions
end up in the tree you know justice my
own idea what animal just I watch a lot
of musicians videos like nobody's doing
drum covers of songs and maybe I'll
watch them maybe I'll learn something
you don't follow youtubers I feel like
there's two types of people there's like
people that cuz there's so much great
stuff on YouTube like tutorials and
documentaries and stuff you learn I
watch that [ __ ] I don't get it like you
don't annoys me the worst is when
there's like say something happens like
okay so you were showing me that clip or
whatever the the the little fellow there
slide known as me right yes the face
grind so it's just like it'll just say
little person epic face grind right and
then it comes on and all of a sudden
this guy okay you're not gonna [ __ ]
face like and it's like this isn't even
your [ __ ] content and like there's so
many and O's yeah so I'm sure I haven't
seen the good ones because there's an
art form to all of it but I always just
feel like it's always like you know
eyebrows up super high energy then he
starts the show right for now watch this
I mean it's like someone who doesn't
want to tell a [ __ ] story
and if the thing should be over in like
30 seconds and now I got to sit through
[ __ ] three minutes of your [ __ ]
that is kind of a meme on YouTube was
like the tutorials where you're like
okay I'm gonna show you how to use
Photoshop and then like 10 minutes 20
seconds in mm-hmm
after describing this whole life story
he gets to the point no you know it's
the worst that was expert village oh you
all made a video about extra I love
expert village don't you bet you've been
around the worst excitability reason you
brought them
they were the [ __ ] I want to show you
some of my favorite I was playing guitar
named Jojo for expert village Accio and
it was always wrong
well I always stuck in it because any
expert village was a phenomenon
I loved it we made one of my most
cherished videos about no one was an
expert exactly nobody wasn't that they
were its tutorials about like how to
make a cheese melt and put it in the
microwave for two seconds and that's the
long wait I got to show you how to flirt
just I hate it and then they they were
like they were like you couldn't get
away from him for a while here like go
to a search and show you some all them
you mention expert village I think it's
important to bring you show you what's
up here okay
look at this guy now I've now this video
I love because look how much dead air
there is okay well it's not that's not
he and he'll get blamed that's not his
fault
well either way they uploaded I mean
they could have cut it for Christ's sake
it is his fault because I think they
make the video and then they submit it
to expert village and then expert
village puts it up so here we go to size
the lighting with your shadow on the
back Walter look at that you're getting
seduced hi this is all we got sound
oh I'm the social dynamics instructor
and on behalf of expert if I kept a girl
at a bar I don't flirt with the girl
picking up women in bars and clubs
flirting what is it mmm
the basics of flirting is to convey
through certain ideas and emotions that
you like someone else hmm and hopefully
that the other person likes you back now
who are the best florists in the world
they're actually little kids now why is
that one of the one thing they have the
best imaginations I was already feeling
you know sexiest people in the world
little kids
Fanbox and they're talking about some
fantastic place that they can go put
themselves in a place that's just the
two of them in their own special world
using their imagination also little kids
are how do you do that as an adult
they're really date rape drug
get her drowsy way but you gotta get to
the what what do you want Michelle oh
we're news like the eyeball thing it's
just it's kind of a long words if I see
a girl with blue eyes I might say wow
your your eyes are like blueberries wait
can I actually actually I'm kind of
hungry can I can I have that's one thing
you could go into oh that always bad I
stick my fingers in your eye
not even so hot yeah you know who are
the sexes you know where the mess of law
yeah these are the guys are like
blueberries blueberries was the wrong
word yeah good good but then you start
doing the little into the carrot I feel
really welcome to squash your [ __ ]
eyes look at these are their experts
anyway love expert village have you
Misha
hey you remember this lady I'm asking
about this I like I like your hands you
like this remember this lady no I've
known of the fail videos the woman
stepping on the grapes and that was
balls off yeah that was just somebody
never you know wind knocked out of him
before so she didn't notice stop talking
you know I used to hear that on Howard
Stern all the time and I never know
what's from and I thought it was felt
like a crazy orgy sound like I never
knew and then when I saw him I got
obviously I got a pulled up now she's
smashing grapes right grape lady ric
flair videos here you go this is it
right here these buckets are filled with
grapes what kind of great these are
filled with Chambertin grapes and the
winner this Saturday you stomps the most
juice will actually win an overnight
stay yours go along you're running dry
yeah that banana crepe [ __ ] that balls
there's extra steps though 19 million
bits
I mean it is kind of one of that's
things ever lie the stomping grapes
gonna juice it it's competitive because
you get a overnight stay
going on here I just it's alive it's
just up on that platform that woman is
that soundbite man I love it you can't
beat it you remember this lady if you
talked about her
I didn't play enough but I want to show
you I want to remind you of this this
great lasers like your hands the handler
like to say that my hands look good
naked they are really just the perfect
neutral toned hand so this she's the
homonymous it's very even I say just
keep petting her yeah yeah yeah this
creepy dude you much creepy [ __ ] wow
this is good you know that stuff that
we've made videos about you're very
protective was it going on I want to ask
you about this this is one of the first
times I heard about you I was in college
I think at the time it was when you were
getting booed by thousands of people I
was like when you said my favorite um
two videos like Oh God not the Philly
thing again and then you did the sharise
berries I was like I love this podcast
now I hate you what can I do I love that
you've you've talked about this a lot
probably more than the grape lady I
didn't realize no but I go ahead let's
know it well now
like makes it get bit I like making well
what am I saw what am i yeah right and
now what do you want me to be well what
was going through your head bill when
you I don't remember it was what was
going through your head I'm kidding this
is this is live this is gonna end up on
YouTube was what I was what I was
thinking and because everything else on
the tour was ending up on YouTube so
that yeah I guess that's what was going
so no I think I thought that afterwards
I'm like well that's gonna be
embarrassing because I didn't know how
people are gonna take it I thought
people just say oh you got booed you
[ __ ] stink and blah blah I didn't
know that people were gonna find it
funny fortunately they did you did kind
of win the audience over did you feel
that while you're on the stage or was it
just like these people hate my guts the
whole time cuz it was no I just thought
it was a complete failure mmm I have no
idea and uh well I don't know how many
of our fans have seen it I've got to
pull up a clip oh go ahead good god we
should skip this no no go ahead boys
just skip I should have been more of I
should've been a better sport no you're
a good sport you do anything you're
being authentic you look you're at that
thing
now this is just gonna now this is the
kind of thing that somebody who buys a
dog does right yeah really get me deep
down get down to the family now this is
just gonna be about me being
uncomfortable showing you this video I
imagine there's a bunch of comments
though now go now [ __ ] you the Eagles
beat the Patriots I would think that
there'd be a bunch of that someone needs
to animate this two years ago but the
video quality is [ __ ] weird like it
anyway yeah I'm sorry you guys but for
me that was when I first heard about you
was that a big moment in your career
like did you get a lot of recognition
because it kind of went viral back then
I mean that's the first timer to you
yeah one I got I got a you know respect
from other comedians which was probably
the thing that I remember most but as
far as like people coming out to the
comedy clubs to see I don't think that
that happened I guy the reason I when I
started drawing on the road was because
I did a I did a half-hour on HBO and I
was sitting in for Jim Norton on the
Opie and Anthony show because he was
doing lucky Louie at the time when Louie
CK was at HBO
so I kind of had those two things hit at
one time and then so I was able to kind
of get the coasts in Oh name mark not
not the south but sort of I had the East
Coast and then I had like San Francisco
I could do well in and then open it they
they they were good right through like
Cleveland so and then Opie and Anthony
also would run like you know they you
know they didn't have the budget at X M
I think it was back then to pay us for
our appearances on the show so they
would let us literally cut commercials
about where we were gonna be and they
were really funny and it was you know is
one of the cool like it was really cool
that they did that and it was a major
reason why you know all of us started
selling tickets so I really moved that
show I really do
how did the comedian's react because I
remember some guy tried to Yankee
offstage towards the end he was like a
how about the the next comedian that
happen I don't even remember that here I
got it I got it
thought you've seen it so many times why
would I want to relive that what else we
had a headache for like two days after
really really well you were really
stressed out afterwards about it I was I
remember walking around New York the
next day looking at people thinking of
insults it was not a fear was it wasn't
a wholesome experience now you're
getting booed by 10,000 people so you
just kind of get in that fight-or-flight
mode so of skills
ducking that I remember riding home with
Robert Kelly that night it was late and
being nervous about like that it was
coming out he goes - do you realize what
the [ __ ] happened tonight you just told
the whole city of Philadelphia to go
[ __ ] themselves
yeah and I was sitting there going like
man when that [ __ ] hits you - tomorrow
everyone's gonna laugh at me and just be
like all you got moving stats see that
to me is interesting because when I
watch that I'm like this is on [ __ ]
fire
yeah and he's authentic and it must feel
incredible to tell 10,000 people to go
[ __ ] themselves and like the most poetic
way it felt good to do it but I I the
perception of it when I left was what I
was I was worried about I mean I was
wasn't had just started selling tickets
in places and then all of a sudden
there's this clip and then it's gonna
live forever on the internet out of me
getting booed and this there's stuff up
there of comics having bad sets and it
didn't help them and I'm thinking like
mm-hmm that's gonna happen for me
I mean it's how do you get booed and it
helps your career I'm out of fighting
well--there's in this case that did but
I mean I didn't have any reference to
that oh you get out of the [ __ ]
business so I was worried if people were
going to understand the kind of crowd
that I was in front of haven't said that
like I love Philly crowds and I was love
the city and I'm happy you know it
sucked that my team lost to him but I
was really happy for them that they can
finally got a Super Bowl oh well I loved
that moment I loved everything you do
the great great is I turn it around
where are you uncomfortable now you
[ __ ] cop I almost made it through
though myself I got so close are you
talking I had a great time I did - I
really did I hope you did I'm worried
about you I did I'm playing it up all
right
but I play trying to be funny but we are
all worried about it live for right just
looking at Dawg guys he'll always happen
he's a great one bottom I bought them
from ml by the way yeah and you said I
appreciate what you people do here at
this
well Instagram photo do you got to do
that you stare at it with the receipt
area me fitted the puppy mill you can't
believe how many dogs they have here oh
by the way it was kind of I was
surprised when I went to the puppy mill
it was a nice wholesome experience the
guy he really cared about the dogs the
dogs who didn't know you were coming or
did I gave my call any that yeah you
were coming
well people popped in while we were
there you think they're just like
unchain like you didn't see the bait
dogs and all that [ __ ] actually it was a
it was more of a breeder than like a
mall yeah like a puppy in a shredded
newspapers situation how many dogs are
there only two like the one that we got
and another one sold out no more
inventory there you go you know they're
outlawed puppy mills in California or
not cow in la la
you can't sell puppies in Los Angeles
you have to go to Thousand Oaks or
Orange County how about that didn't know
that all right that's amazing
I wondered why at the Beverly Center
that pet store went away yes and I
thought it was because of people
reacting to that somebody they don't
care about the fish that are in there
though huh yeah the gerbils and all
those other things that used to be free
yeah we only care about dogs it is true
what dogs need something cuz they took
the wolf out of them so they need
somebody to kind of help move along my
dog would not last a day
no not even an hour on his own you would
never see when they take the fangs out
of a Cobra
no I mean I know they doesn't know that
so it's still like doing all that [ __ ]
well that's how they do you never see
that one with a baby just goes up and
grabs the snake they like they did a
thing where they like I don't know they
sewed its [ __ ] mouth shut it was a
loose brutal yeah but the first time you
see you see this baby crawling up to a
cobra you and you're like freaking out
and then they just it's like grabbing on
to it and the Cobras like basically like
head-butting it's like the most
aggressive way it's hot well that's a
bad lesson for a baby by the way don't
play with snakes yeah you would think
that would be the direction you don't
know man
you know like they somehow guys you know
get pregnant right is that he's supposed
to say it
you get pregnant like you're a seahorse
right just yet just steer them away from
the snakes have them respect the snake
respect the snakes Bella thank you you
little [ __ ] this is my house I'm running
stuff so I want to thank bill Berg guys
go to billboard.com slash events he's
playing at Madison Square Garden
November 7th I'm excited for you I'm
thrilled it's gonna be a great show
everyone get out there if you've got
Netflix which I know you do if you don't
have it your dad your girlfriend
somebody has got it for Christ's sake
watch f is for family season one or two
threes coming out soon yes and of course
and thank you to Wild West Vince Vaughn
Peter Billingsley Mike Price Victoria
Vaughn everybody that helps me Netflix
and mmm everybody helps me do the show
cuz I think this is gonna be our best
season going on it of course yeah it's
all good stuff cool so guys thank you so
much for watching
look at the camera to you they don't
think they can see you we show be show
bill thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you on Friday for top of the
week we got a lot to talk about and kill
Tony I don't know if you're acquainted
with those sweet guys are gonna be here
on season two I know those get very very
funny gentlemen good people good people
yeah all right what are you gonna say
Tony you are the greatest greatest
comedian I do it to everybody and I
don't I swear to God I don't but you
know what I'm telling man I would either
count I'm gonna say I appreciate you
time let's hone it all the way down
he'll Tony I love his car okay well now
I'm curious what it's this car club will
talk about yeah yeah it's not Tuesday
okay cool we don't we don't the great
billboard doesn't have time for that all
right bye guys thanks for watching
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you